hidey-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey cool torches seen from
Vikings I don't know if any of them
sound like any like another probably -
accents in here fraud it is on the
History Channel so there might be more
accurate you see one of our top of war
tears over our patreon page is whatever
video you request we must definitely do
put up on the youtubes whether that is a
review podcast or a reaction today's
another reaction for Vikings aivars most
badass scene you can't kill me this one
comes from Christina Goodman Vasquez and
she has a little message here for us cuz
I asked like who's Ernie background for
me she was John I haven't seen the show
but they follow me on Twitter they do
yes why I have no idea specifically yes
means specific why would you do I don't
jump ahead a kid yeah put his head on a
spike mm-hmm why the hell haven't I
gotten recognition I mean it's like 14
kids look you should have done it first
John and for the back one of the Vikings
Ragnar huh looks like a regular rock
rock had 12 sons all of them were famous
Vikings but I bar the boneless was a
famous Viking that rated England for 10
plus years back in ad 865 I've kept up
with all of that and history people saw
that he arrived in battle they fled he
was so fear that they always ran some
stayed there was ran some stayed I'm
gonna encourage you to use a little more
punctuation works again grammarly fight
the ones I was really brave
but posts ran from the battle some
believed he was a [ __ ] also so with
the great heat in an army and his
brothers the actor that plays our the
bows is a really good actor epic
continues him for a while to the show
hands okay so I've heard the boneless
IRA the Bona is a badass famous Viking
the rated England for 10 plus years
people were so scared of him he may have
been a [ __ ] he's a badass watch this
seed from thickens
[Music]
damn is the season 5 watch the show this
show is like secretly super popular on
the show whoa history this video is not
suitable for advertisers
maybe that may be the pixel
oh wow okay that guy has no excuse is he
giving to all these people
[Music]
British accent just shoot him would you
I know as your link it was in this show
Oh God
the design was badass st. he's gonna
yell yes Wow that production design on
this I did not know about oh yeah the
glimpses I've seen him in breathtaking
these kind of battle so just freak me
out
[Music]
wolf
is this really his most badass Adisa
you here we go
I just gonna piss mom
so he must have been crippled yeah at
least by the History Channel's telling
of the tale that's why it's called
boatless I get why this is badass now
Wow hmm
I like
yeah he's just only blade
[ __ ] I would have stayed
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
even doing hey guy loves a good battle
I'd be scared to meet that guy in real
life I'm talking about the actor you got
kids or family or you just find
different Viking sets to go yellow
because man that delivery right there
was uh yeah hugely like anytime people
on screen are just really enjoying blood
list I always find that very high
jarring I remember now where I've seen
an image of this guy he was pitched in a
movie fights to play Wolverine oh yeah
he's kind of short stocky crazy yeah
yeah I can see it yeah give him some
some chops and change his hair a little
bit yeah I'll tell you this I've never
seen anything from Vikings and this
actually made me want to check out the
show I I had a prejudgment about it that
it was probably on the oh yes
qualitative side of scripted television
like wow this looks freaking insane this
looks like nerve wracking it looks like
a secret Game of Thrones or something
yeah it's like I'm skipping out on
budget here no I remember when this show
came on and it's funny cuz I haven't I
don't know anybody who like really keeps
up with it but the more I've looked to
add it just online like it seems like it
has a massive fan base like this show is
really popular and the battle scenes
like this I can see why yeah I mean
that's the thing is I wonder from
History Channel like how accurate is
this show well I've always really liked
that when I've seen History Channel
documentaries whenever they do
reenactments I've always really liked
those I've watched those thinking man
they should make like descriptive
television than they do it I'm like as
probably crap look at it like this like
a damn good TV right here mm-hmm
sword battles and arrow stuff like in
those kind of traditional battle formats
always just make me because I could feel
the slicing more than I can feel it all
got like I cut on our hands from a knife
or something like that so there's a sort
of like
oh I'd be more scared of that for
something like oh yeah bullet conjures
up just a concentrated point of pain in
your mind whereas like knives and arrows
have the potential like rip things and
tear flesh and ligaments and do all
kinds of damage that's really messy and
hard to figure out I mean these guys
just get shot with arrows and pull it
out yeah yeah they think Vikings so you
just got to find the right clan then the
right the right plan you know yeah I
think they call it the clan plan and
then you that keeps you incentive to
keep on plundering and stuff like that
because yeah you got a a you know give
up some of that every month
yeah and back and I believe they paid
with food for their health insurance but
I could be wrong about that part of the
currency you guys look good yourself
History Channel real rejects but yeah
dude this guy seems out of his mind
yeah and this is kind of crazy he must
be crippled if he didn't feel anything
in his leg like that happen right well
if he'd never got up I was like okay
yeah but to be that scary and that's
threatening when you can't even move
yeah that's a lot for an actor to take
on you have to be if they actually work
twice as hard to be that imposing in
that scale like no one was shooting the
guy yeah he's like paralyzed Rosi axis
that one guy no that was one touching
him yeah that was one thing I was like
are they supposed to capture him alive
or something or why they could have
killed him like nine times Oh
locate the show all I did the show I was
cool yeah pretty sweet pretty sweet and
of course a before a wrap this video up
alright see have a proper shout out to
Christina Goodman Vasquez Christina
you've been watching us for such a long
time he said all the way back with
amazing spider-man 2 I'm surprised this
is the first time you and I are getting
to know each other she's currently 21
meaning Jon's gonna be dating her soon
that's his age group that he prefers to
go after young he's an older but his
maturity levels right around that age so
makes more sense
lower she's from Texas so you know she's
hot love Texas all Texas girls are hot
especially you name's Christina you
gotta be I asked her order astrology
sign well she said it was cancer as of
the day of filming this it is March 4th
so I decided to look up the cancer
horoscope cuz I wanted to get an insight
on how you're feeling it says here that
for today March 4th so great news there
could be a great deal of friction in
your world today get down with cancer as
stubborn Minds aggressively come into
conflict with each other
ooh you do strike me as a stubborn woman
be careful how you treat others don't be
a [ __ ] because feelings are likely to
be hurt if you're insensitive fool man
you sound like John's type others may
look tough I know you can really cut the
heart with words that are like like
blades sharpened but deep down they're
just as soft as you are oh you're like
Tony Stark or like Ivar think twice
about using your aggressive nature at
the expense of others man you sound like
one tough ass [ __ ] and I like it I
like it a lot you keep that attitude
don't listen to this was astrology [ __ ]
man unclip those crab claws from Texas
man freakin shoot people do whatever you
got to do to maintain that attitude yeah
gosh give other people cancer if you
can't I don't know how you do that but
find a way to do it okay sure don't try
to be nice to people people don't
deserve it people are jerks yeah push
the elderly downstairs and kids into
traffic whatever you got to do to get
your job ask yourself ww ID what would I
do
[Laughter]
no but in all seriousness Christina
thank you so much for being here you
seem like a really sweet girl and I
appreciate all the support you've given
us hope you continue to watch and I hope
this shoutout was read as purely
sarcastic and not as sincere if not feel
free to tweet about me hopefully I
finally get an interview on Access
Hollywood are they still around yes but
now it's just cold access guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about and check us on
patreon we got so many shitty things